Hey guys you're listening to a best of
on hey babe we will be back with a brand
new episode for you next Thursday s and
I in the building but for this week
enjoy the best of Reminisce have fun
kiss everyone on the lips hey everybody
last week of my tour before I filmed my
special in Chicago at the Vic theater
December 1st and 2nd tickets are still
available right now for that you can get
them on salvano comedy.com this is the
last week I'm performing this material
tonight we're in Appleton everybody
how'd you guys like the show
tonight
[Music]
a
tour dates are on sale right now at
salcano comedy.com there's a big
Illinois run in November leading up to
my comedy special the Vic in Chicago on
December 1st and 2nd the second sold out
as you guys I hopefully know uh and so
we edit two shows on the first all will
be taped and all if you have a ticket to
any of those shows you'll be eligible to
win uh a flight hotel and trip to the
set of Impractical Jokers I'm choosing
one ticket out of those four shows uh
December 1st is still on sale right now
but it's going fast savano comedy.com
hope to see you guys on the road what's
up everybody tomorrow night I am at
standup live in Phoenix Arizon a two
shows tomorrow two shows Saturday almost
all sold out then the following weekend
I'm in Salt Lake City at Wise Guys all
those shows are sold out and then
Saturday December 9th at the Paramount
in Denver Colorado again almost sold out
the only ticket you can get me for is
January 12th and 13th in San Diego and
then January 13th at the wilt turn in
Los Angeles Chris DC comedy.com for
Ticky wikies and then February wearing
Nashville DC and Reno Christy comedy.com
for tikiwiki brand new hour of material
uh uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe hey babe so
first question how is the afterlife yes
so actually it's crazy on November 2nd
you on November 2nd at 1:18 p.m. I
passed away did you see Saddam Hussein
in the afterlife no I'm telling you I
went dark you don't you didn't wow maybe
you were in purgatory is that possible
he didn't go you didn't go to heaven or
hell only one person came to me who in
the in the in the eight weeks one person
who was it Kan
Tanaka Kane Tanaka because I think she
oversees something down there Kan Tanaka
she's like the gate like the gatekeeper
oh you went down down there well I don't
know did you subconscious I am dead
inside right as we all are she is our
basically our Muse and we love this
woman Yolanda Vega on the podcast would
be a great get we want to get Yolanda
Vega on this podcast we'd like to maybe
she could even do the if you're friends
with her if you're family with her we'd
love to get Yolanda on yes if you're a
friend or family member of Yolanda Vega
this and if you don't know her since I'm
a young person uh this is the woman who
draws the New York State lottery numbers
and she has a little calling card and
this is what she
says you ready for this
y
isn't that amazing the best do you
think I love you do you think I love you
too do you think that she came up with
that or you think like she was just on
the air one day I saw parents named
to uh no I think that she probably just
I don't know like she's a broadcaster in
a sense right she just did it so I'm
Yola if you're from New York there is
nothing it's that's as New York as a
bodega she is as new saying is New York
through and through you can actually and
it probably at times must be tough to be
her cuz when she walks she's the type of
person say New York City if she's
walking through the streets I would say
a 100 times a day people are yelling
Yolanda
Vega don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey bab hey bab hey bab
hey thanks to my my husband Miguel I am
hey babe youra Vega oh my God we got it
a dream has come true Yolanda Vega you
are the first guest Miss Vega yes you're
the first guest that we set out loud oh
my God we wish we can get her onia and
we just threw it out into the universe a
year ago more more we threw it out it
was 2021 one of my co-workers sandre at
the lottery came over to me may actually
and she said hey they're playing in in
Albany you want to come see the show s
loves you no offense Chris it was s and
and I said no I can't but what's going
on she says could you make an autograph
for him and I did so I will let's we
have a lot to go through today we have a
lot to go through I received this
beautiful and I brought this on the
someone I'm so sorry I forgot who gave
me this Sandra but but I I Sandra do I
know Sandra probably not but someone she
handed it to some someone gave me this
and I'm I'm sorry I forgot who it was I
really am but I was always like I wonder
if this is real because you know it just
came to me from nowhere and I'm like it
looks real and it says hi Sal volcano
and it's got a dollar sign up at the top
there it it says hope to meet you uh
when you win good luck best regards
Yanda 2021 PS you crack me up and I was
like I can't believe this I brought this
on I'm like the queen has responded and
cuz we were tell I was telling you
before this what you mean to New Yorkers
and I think you know that the big you're
you're and you know especially the New
Yorkers you know I my children are are
Puerto Rican so so you know as Puerto
Ricans um we only there's only two
people who I want my daughters to be
either Yolanda Vega or Fat Joe that's
and and and those are you are the two
king and queen Porter New York PTO Rican
so it's an honor it is oh thank you
thank you and and you are Puerto Rican I
am borua mom and dad born in Puerto Rico
um s s sang andig May yes oh so I was
born in raised in Brooklyn okay Sunset
Park Red Hook baby Red Hook yes I was
going to say baby rich I live there
after I tell people I'm from Bay Ridge
I'm not so Red Hook baby Red Hook I love
Red Hook they got a good Ikea now they
do
now Ikea and Red Hook Tavern that's
great burger um you you said what what
parts of Puerto Rico uh Maya West that's
where my grandma's from oh my God lyia
on the west coast wow yeah look at I'm
percolating that's how excited I am
that's L that's literally where her her
entire family's from she's from 100%
Puerto Rican uh my grandma Lydia Diaz
and uh and then my shout out lyia Diaz
no longer with us no she's she is living
she's 91 or 93 W sure no she's 91 or 94
we don't know probably my my my daddy's
cousin you think so probably from over
there right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so yes so we have a kinship to you and
actually I used to live with my
grandparents uh those those grandparents
and every single night we'd watch like
they have their they'd have their like
routine and they'd watch like Wheel of
Fortune and and right at that time I
think it was 7:00 7:30 or 7:30 and so
we' you'd watch you every night you know
so we grew up on you so this is a big
deal for us is what we're saying big
huge deal literally part of New York
history and um do you know Yolanda that
with the lottery we wanted to ask you
about this because we talk about this a
lot the lottery winners are cursed
whoever wins the lotto they they they
literally they usually die within two or
three years or they go broke what do you
think do you have any tips for people
going to win the lotto out there well
wait first of all that's very very sad
because that's just you get the negative
stories there are a lot of good stories
of lottery winners out there somebody
somebody bought his and hard jet skis as
well like and let let me add the the
biggest lottery winner of all time Mr
Vega who got to marry you that's what
I'd like to say Point thank you I know
how to talk to my Puerto
Ricans I'm going to start to try to
practice poverty once or twice twice a
month what I mean by that is not going
crazy living on the street instead of
driving in cuz I have the luxury of
doing that in parking take the ferry
take the two buses sit coach flying to
you know a city um um just to help
appreciate because then when I get the
opport I didn't even know you were here
get Pig did you just say you're going to
practice poverty by flying coach and
ride the
subway you just described my regular
life he called it
poverty that's
insane he said he said that's one level
above
all one the last day of filming we had
to film three episodes in one day and I
was the host and in front of a live
studio audience and panelists and all
that so you know you start to get like
so tired or whatever so I literally in
front of this is 200 people all the
executives from from from this channel
there and I just thought this will be
hilarious and it'll be like light in the
mood or whatever I ripped the loudest
part off a
chair dead pin drop silence I swear to
God even the panelists just looked at me
and then look back at their phones I
swear to God I just turned and I
adjusted the mic on my shirt I just like
that and sat back and an earpiece in and
I listen to I said guys were ready to go
and then I went back I said welcome back
to the
show yeah my I've always had a confident
confidence in my body an unfounded
confidence but I don't know why that and
on a dance floor the two places where I
shouldn't have confidence in IA so where
where are you insecure then where don't
you have because when I always want
wanted to ask you you go to us for the
rest of this episode right yeah for sure
you want me to take it out Pop a top
off it's hot in you
oh my
God where would you say I don't have
confidence I don't know if there's any
Arena anymore that I don't yeah I didn't
even when I was dating I was pretty
confident all the time um I guess smells
good you not confidence smell smell good
maybe it's all natural I just use some
product in the in the tub yeah no no it
is I do I got a whip you you do a Us in
the tub in the tub yeah my tub product
yeah yeah I use uh what's the name of
that place in La lfl llum it's it's a
high-end
like I use Lao Lao colon number seven I
we got s us Lao s is that what you got
best yeah I showed you santal did you
yeah one time I said smell this and I
opened it up it's from oh no that was
something else that's okay yeah I
smelled labo in um the Thompson Hotel in
La nice that's when I SM I SM it for the
first time in Amsterdam oh did you yeah
they had the I found it an Al They had
in my hotel room they had the stuff I'm
like delicious smell what is this I did
a shampoo uh conditioner the cream is
what sucked me in and I didn't found out
about the shampoo lines wait a second so
what there has to be something you're
insecure about there has to be something
because a man who's just as confident as
you with B you nine times out of 10 the
biggest thing the biggest insecurity is
some is someone with their body that's
usually what it is but it's not you but
that doesn't mean you you're immune to
insecurity no I'm definitely I wouldn't
say I'm immune insecurity I'll find
myself in situations where
I'm I don't know your hair is it your
hairline no my hair I don't care about
that I this fell AP a long time ago I
keep the gray of salt and Pepper's here
I don't give [__] um I've been doing
this since I've been rocking this since
32 uh you know I always been kind of fat
I had the big nose um always kind of a
fat big nose I have bad I have bad uh
you know Arch you know you know my back
like you don't care like you're you're
like you know like you look at me and
you're like you know what I'm a bald big
noosed fat piece of
[__] yeah yeah and I love him and I love
him I love I love every ounce of them I
love every overweight ounce of this guy
uh that's good that that's good to
because a lot of people right I mean if
you think about security and being
insecure it really is ridiculous that
how how we get so hung up on these
microscopic things when it's like we're
only going to be alive for a very short
amount of time even if we live to a 100
and then it's like you're some other
energy but if you people spend their
whole life worried about what other
people think when really nobody really
cares at all right like you're doing 95%
of what we do we do for somebody else
right but Joe seems to live for himself
which is nice it's probably very
liberating which is not selfish it's
what you're supposed to do well you put
it out there for you care about other
people's feelings and other people's you
know their their what nuts but I like to
bring out the best in people too yeah
you bring out those nipples yeah I'm
sitting right here I sit here on my flat
pancake inverted nip and I don't care
about that like what are you going to
worry about at this point like you look
at you you look like you look a Greek
god next to me so I like being the low
the barrier of Entry right right well
why do you like that because I think I
like to make people feel good about
themselves cuz I feel like it's
important I get I'm fat this on purpose
100% I am making myself a disgusting you
look like this like this you look
like you're welcome you're welcome you
look like this cuz you are actively
trying to make other people feel better
this this is why I walk around like this
I eat pounds and pounds I take 32,000
words of calories yeah you were saying
that and I was like I've seen him do
this like 10 times so Joe when I just
told you about my eating that it did not
Shock you you were like all right the
guy ate a little bit too much today
you've done that before I've eaten yeah
hard I I I'm an eater well it's it's
really what it is is the pastries and
the cookies and stuff like that sweet
Toth i' be Hond you have a box of
pastries alone yeah cholesterol issues
blood pressure issues one time he ate so
much SP Fe on camera cheesec on camera
he ate a [__] cheesecake that was
then in the CLA that was this big he
just kept eating it was like huge it was
like this big eat two of them and then
we were filming and he got flush and
lightheaded and he felt like he was
going to pass out we had to call the
ambulance and they Mar was having a
great turn so I told him to keep going
and I'm in the back getting checked out
by the medic the ambulance came he's in
the back beat red sweating they taking
his hot heart uh and and they were like
does anything out of the ordinary
happened and he was like no and I'm like
what are you talking about you just ate
8,000 calories in in literally 4 minutes
just for the joke ate it really fast so
I'm like your body can't handle that you
just ate 8,000 calories in 5 minutes I
was coming down off a sugar high in a
bad way in a bad you like something I I
turn to him I'm St next to I tapped I
went something's not
right he was like got that the other
time when uh remember we were in uh we
were filming you were getting punished
you were out in London or Wickham
Warriors yes there's a there's a
professional soccer team out I I I guess
in Wickham called the Wickham Warriors
and we we filmed the punishment on their
field with them the whole team and Joe
and James had to be in net as the
goalies and the whole team just kept
kicking balls professional
so dude and they got just jacked
immediately and fell down to the ground
and they kept hitting him then at the
end he didn't know this but just I guess
I don't know why but all they impromptu
they did an impromptu Pyon dog pile dog
pile so grown men football players and
I'm on the bottom with M and Murray had
just fallen and so I was holding Murray
but I was like sitting up and this you
know 40 grown Englishman jump there it
is a dog pile on me and I'm on the
bottom of this but my leg is one way and
my back's the other way and I'm on the
bottom of that so are you screaming I am
I'm screaming to get off me I even
punched one guy in the neck to get him
off me I swear to God I punched a wick
him right in the throat he wouldn't get
off he thought it was funny like they
kept jumping watch it's this one [__]
here he's that one see him goes hi I was
I was I don't know if you can see it I
was from the bottom do like I was
listening to Zombie
Nation like hitting him in the throat to
get off me and they get off what you
actually really getting nervous they
pulled we had first of all we had to
rush to make a flight we had to rush to
make a flight and they pulled they
peeled all the guys off you ever seen in
the cartoons when someone gets right
over by like a steamroller like in the
like all twisted that he was like a foot
into the ground yeah turn around down he
couldn't move he couldn't move they peel
him up and then they took us into the
locker rooms and they laid him down dude
he this is one of my best friends by the
way one of the most hurt I ever was he
was he was locked his body was locked so
my leg my leg my hip locked so I
couldn't take I couldn't I couldn't
unstraightened so when I lay down on the
floor my leg was like this one arm arm
was all the way behind his back I spray
my shoulder he took his shirt off took
my shirt and then you were bright you
were bright pink like a [__] in I was
in conference room in the back they put
us in a conference room and I'm laying
in his his whole body was pink like cuz
it was I don't the pressure he was it
just bright pink and he was sweating he
look like a [__] Canam yeah and they
were touching his body and he's going I
can't I can't they're trying to unpop my
shoulder like thing I have pictures of
you on the floor cuz we we're waiting a
picture waiting for the we're like we're
going to miss the flight what are we
going to do yeah and it took like 10
minutes and they had to like they had to
like move him slowly back into his
normal position you know those gumy toys
you know that you bend their arms and
stuff that's exactly what I look like
like my arm was like stuck it was but it
was you're so funny like you're just so
visually funny to me like you're such a
funny physical person that like the way
you were locked up and on the floor just
I was still making jokes you still in
pain something about like I know you
were in pain but like there's something
about that you were in
pain that was so funny I don't
understand I don't want to get into it
but I don't understand how anything
started not even the Big Bang okay like
it doesn't make any sense how does
[Music]
anything anything as far back and as far
out as you want to go
exist what made matter what was there
before it I know that this sounds like a
high College bongs talk and I know it
might be trit and I know it might be
like people talk about all the time but
I still will never be able to wrap my
head around it and I don't think anyone
can give me an answer well I don't think
number one I don't think that some of
those answers are even designed for our
brain to compute be able to comprehend
what I will say is even you have a piece
of the puzzle even blow your balls off
even more is there is a lot of theories
out there now that not
only is you know the the our universe
and all that and and all the universes
that have ever existed that we have
gotten to this point before and that we
this might be the eighth or some people
believe the ninth existence of us
throughout however long time it's been
so we think our universe started four
billion years ago and maybe it or
whatever the number is and maybe it has
but that's this that's the eighth
existence there have been things that
had happened all the do you recall why
they specifically said eight or like so
here's what they I why I don't know why
they said eight or nine I've I I have um
that I I don't know I was uh spotting a
guy at the gym and he was talking to me
about this I he so and and but but uh
press bench press bench press how many
how many reps was he's a strong guy he
did about he did about 10 at at at 270
when you put your hand on there do you
ever lift more than you tell let on to
give them a little confidence I try to
be honest with them but sometimes I
could you know he was he was a rageful
man clearly on steroids yelling at me
about when the universe began so I
wanted to just tell him I didn't barely
touch it all I'm just guiding you but by
the way when you're when you're spotting
a guy at the bench press there's no no
way to not teabag him you're always
teabagging him yeah and you just have to
accept that or at least it's too close
for comfort your testes in his forehead
your balls are the closest to another
man's forehead they might ever be unless
you're a gay man right so or you're
experimenting on the weekends it is
Fleet Week I mean when you go over the
pond right over there yes uh a lot of
these countries they they have the um
biggest output of supermodels but then
they also like I think it's all or
nothing over there sometimes they have
the biggest output of but every six foot
tall supermodel you see is is is from
yeah you they got one that looks like
one girl that looks like a a supermodel
other girl looks like Borat yeah that's
what you get that's you get my wife I'm
very monogamous too and I love my
boyfriend a lot so what is very
monogamous is it monogamous monogamous
yeah cuz that's like um it's like
redundant right just monogamous how do
you how are you even you said I'm very
monogamous what does that mean I some
people like don't like I don't cheat
there's no but that's monogamous but
some people are monogamous and they
still
cheat
but where we get the good and the bad
through our foods like what's what's
good and what's bad so HDL the good
cholesterol typically gets raised with
exercise the bad cholesterol the ldls
and the triglycerides get high with
eating you know uh you know Foods
saturated with s you know saturated with
s say it saturated with sat saturated
with sad Foods saturated sat is a fun
name saturated is that the name of the
episode Special saturated sat saturated
sat saturated sat not exercising yeah
all right the disguise o the disguise I
wonder what this is about this is about
putting on a front maybe a little bit
yeah oh I mean sexy I'm not saying for
the quality of the video look at this I
mean kid handsome right kid he's a good
looking kid he's a good looking kid he
really is a good looking kid yeah head
buzzed okay look at that how many years
ago F this was probably 2007 I was in
the throws of a [__] bad cocaine ad
addiction oh my goodness what this is in
Philly huh this is in Sunnyside Queens
oh wow oh wait who's playing the drums
Sals uh drum machine here we go were you
already doing stand up you had started
your standup career
[Music]
already right this is you this me wow is
that's your voice why you
always oh my
god there it is the last time ever are
you kidding
me what how do you how did you discover
you could sing one day you weren't
singing like that your whole life
no do you want to make the new intro
song for hey babe it must have been
fascinating when you realize you can
sing like that was it fascinating I
never thought it was really that good to
be honest no FY this is this is awesome
dude look at that reading a little
Colombian
newspaper you're holding a perfect
note I didn't know you had my child's
mother in the
video hey Jazz also the song is good
like you know how to write a how' you
know how to write a song it up and you
did this whole thing by yourself
[Music]
everything this one
yes I recorded this on my Mac um desktop
no garage man
yeah dude this is a I I like love this
song thank you
buddy there it is there's the Foley we
know sleeping on the subway sleeping on
the subway
wow who's this that's my buddy what's he
doing now I don't know uh he's a
professor is he yeah nice my best friend
growing up what subject English
okay I don't take a for an English te be
honest good looking does I don't look at
him and see English good he looks like
he's preparing for a sexual assault on
this
[Music]
woman dude this is
awesome
I love
it oh there you go this is
hot there's got
baby wait I'm sorry does she like him or
not she does okay I it's me completely
misinterpreting a situation okay got you
gotcha
oh amazing have you your fans have seen
this already right I think so we played
it on uh something before Legion of
ganks oh yeah they buried me they weren
they weren't so receptive to
it what were they say what were their
problems
with it was great it was great they
weren't yeah they weren't so you two are
Kinder Souls didn't start up a fan club
immediately no Jay did like a very
Fallout Boy thing when I see her's look
in my eyes I'm AG Voli listen guys if
you know the hay Bay podcast you know
the thing that s and I love the most is
meat in our mouth and butcher box has
all you need for a tasty stress-free
holiday season with high quality protein
delivered right to your door you have
peace of mind easily High easily find
high quality meat and see food you can
trust 100% grass-fed beef free range
organic chicken pork raised crate free
and wild CAU Seafood yummy yummy in my
tummy humanely raised no antibiotics or
added hormones that's important because
a lot of these meats out there they have
all this other stuff in it and you're
getting much more than the protein and
it's not good but with butcher box you
get only what you need the protein
Quality quality meat you get exclusive
member deals you receive inspiration
guides tips and hacks for cooking your
meat and eating and it's a beautiful
beautiful beautiful thing now of course
for listening to the hey bay podcast we
always got a discount for you people
always always always so sign up today at
butcherbox.com heyab and use the code
hey bab that's H YB a be to get free
chicken wings for a year let me repeat
that folks if you go to butcherbox.com
heyab and you use the code hey babe
you're going to get free chicken wings
for a year how could you not do that
you're going to get free chick wings for
a year that's three pounds of Freer
range organic chicken wings free in
every order for a year when you sign up
at butcherbox.com
heyab and use the code heyab go do it
protein this episode is sponsored by
betterhelp thank you to the people at
betterhelp for sponsoring us thank you
for doing what you do listen especially
now on holidays and all that everybody
needs therapy everybody needs to talk
about something everybody has something
that they need to get off their chest
and better help is the best place for it
it is all done entirely online you do
not have to go to any brick and mortars
you don't have to commute there it's all
done entirely online you basically fill
out a survey I've done this you fill out
a like a little questionnaire form and
they match you based off your answers
with the right therapist for you um I've
been using it it really really really
works um I benefit from therapy and I
benefit from better help um you know
therapy can be a bright spot amid all of
the stress and change something to look
forward to to make you feel grounded and
to give you the tools to manage
everything you got going on this time of
year as I said can be a lot and it's
natural to feel sadness or anxiety about
it that's why the good Folks at
betterhelp are there to help you if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
betterhelp a try it's done entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule you
just fill out the brief questionnaire as
I'm mentioned to get mats with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge I love
that about them find your bright spot
this season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com heab today to get 10% off
your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com he's bouncing off my booty cheeks
I love the way he writes I can hardly
breathe when he's pumping deep inside he
kisses on my neck and then I kiss him on
his busy call him daddy while I hollow
man that boy so damn good
looking cuz I want to quit comedy every
day and I'm I'm too scared because I I
don't know if he has health insurance
and I have to pay for his bow movements
his b Rec construction never ends never
ends with him now that he's Upp you know
he's pretty Upp now
so I'm opting Money Changes people yeah
exactly dude what are you talking about
tampon just y he lived on Staten Island
I lived in Queens this guy never missed
a baseball practice never missed a
baseball practice a game nothing my dad
missed some
stuff he missed a lot of I wasn't
allowed nervous Nelly over
here pretty nervous Nelly that also
might be the title of the
party I was at Casey Jose's bachelor
party in in New Orleans we went to a
laser tag place all of a sudden Casey's
phone is not in his jacket all go into
this booth with security guard sure as
[__] a middle-aged woman just walks in
there closes the door behind her walks
up and it's and we watch her do it she
an employee no let's actually witnessed
how about this she's still there so we
see her there we have her on the the
tape right so everyone's like what are
we going to do what are we going to do
she's still here like this is crazy was
she playing laser tank this is she was
there with her kid bro right and so
we're like this is going to come to a
head how does this work itself out they
call the police and we're like well what
if she leave leaves she we can't we
can't really hold her back but I don't
know so then everyone goes and stays at
all the doors because we we want to make
sure that we don't lose this is a good B
party talk about this if he wanted to
get plastic surgery or she or they I
would understand because they have a
condition called hyper chosis also known
as werewolf syndrome only around 50
people in history have ever had it and
he has it where he just grows hair 50
people in history history yeah
history history wild there's 8 billion
now but that's not including all the
people how many people [__] have we had
on Earth over trillions does anyone take
a like a since the census started how
many people we've had like turnover
including
turnover discoveries now suggests uh
200,000 BCE okay 117 billion members of
our species have been born on Earth wow
117 billion members and he's and there's
been less than 50 cases of the werewolf
syndrome yep and he's got it and not for
nothing but he's
he's walking around like that because he
took a selfie I think you lean into it
like we shouldn't even know unless he
wants to yeah but you can't lean can you
play it as much as I would want to be
able to just look past that I
don't okay is that real no that's it's a
real condition many of them worked as
promoted as having distinct human animal
tra is there no Googs is there no
vs oh my God
that's rough yeah well what do you got
to do then shave it every day I don't I
don't think it matters I think you would
have to shave I think it grows so fast
there's probably no surgery for it
because who's going to concentrate all
that money when it's that rare yeah
who's going to do the research for it
laser huh do laser you think you can do
laser and he just opted not to it's
laser I mean that's that's where I could
see a gofund me right that's where I
could see it not like I want to go you
know right people that's a Gund me she
like hey I'm a werewolf I need a couple
of million this girl who has I just want
to become a boy again her smile is is
funny that can't it's a it's a they
picked a bad smile pick where she just
looks like she just farted and her eyes
yeah it's not good they shouldn't have
used this photo she's like mugging yeah
yeah oh that's that's it's horrible that
is not
good I mean what what is your life like
you know I mean it's I I want to I would
beg to difference it's not easy it's not
like Teen Wolf a buttlift is not going
to make a difference Teen Wolf is fun
you're not banging the girl and winning
shooting the winning shot no I would say
no yeah but all right well I mean what
can you do I don't think they can do
anything they that's a rare condition
that I wouldn't want that I wouldn't
want that what about this one then we
got Ella Harper AKA camel girl she was
born with a rare condition that caused
her knees to bend backwards like Shane
McMahon because of this condition she
had to walk on all fours earning her the
nickname camel girl though it was
difficult At first she made a fortune
out of it she earned a weekly wage of
$200 in 1886 that's a big bucks what's
that now just for infl $200 now from
1886 I'm going to guess $200 a week now
in that would be that would be $3,000 a
week think today's money if I to guess
oh 6,000 6500 a week that's real money
wow wow now hold on a second let's see
what she was making a year
30 three 380,000 three 340 just about
340 so she was wow that's you know how
much back then how much 200 a week would
get you my grandfather went to the
movies for a nickel that was in the like
mid 1900 you could buy a house back then
for 200 flat you make it in one week you
buy the house outright yeah
she's just probably trotting around the
house yeah uh Is that real is this real
cuz that looks like a that picture looks
pretty like iphon and there are a lot of
sick [__] out there that look at this
and they're probably going to masturbate
to that photo cuz she looks bent over
let's hope not oh that's insane oh I'm
that's sad that is sad but it would be
nice to say you had sex with C girl if
we're just being honest if we're just
being open and honest I wonder if she
had ask you a question I'm going to ask
you a question for the night you have to
have and you have to have sex with of
them you going for Camel girl or
werewolf face you have to have sex with
one of them they're both they're both
women I'm going to do camel girl okay
yeah okay fair enough pimp it's I'm
gonna do her I'm gonna I'm goingon to
choose her you choose camel girl I do a
threesome nice with camel girl and and
werewolf boy yeah why the hell not get a
little bit of it all exactly I like that
I like that and I yeah I like that I'd
have Snoop bre it what about you who you
taking I'd go with i' I'd say I'd go
with camel girl she's a pretty good
pretty girl i' go with camel girl um but
I would say that i' i' take werewolf boy
maybe I I I try to I I try to have an
intimate night with werewolf uh boy you
would want to do a little camel
style doing a camel style is you know
you know what they say when you when you
sleep with her all it takes is one
hump this beenin hey
babe oh it no right I don't always mean
to give you a hand job but it just it's
it Happ truth is the truth dude there's
no one really better than you dude if
you're going to get a hand jum from some
of those sounds the guy very soft hands
for a man for like a guy who's you know
like a straight man softest hands in the
straight male Community sound volcano
even the stuff that people talk [__]
about me on it's so whatever there some
young Comics who all into their sneaker
[__] or whatever so if that your beef
with me fine and then there was a time
where some snitch [__] in
La where can people see you next except
for the snitch [__] yeah except for
that snitch bat
snitch [__] you know who you are we
don't but you know that's enough to do
was come to me like a man after the show
and go hey there's another comedian with
a similar thought but you didn't do that
did you cuz you like
[Music]
drama fight on ecstasy once in a how
does that work we're in this in this bar
and we're having a good time something
happens there's a commotion I see my
friend Ryan get kind of rushed out of
the bar so I ran out there and my friend
Ryan like the kid immediately took off
his shirt he like threw it at me for I
grabbed it and like rubbed my face with
it and immediately like threw a punch at
this kid and all of the sudden I'm like
on ecstasy and I am the best boxer I've
ever
been every move in your head no in real
life in like every fiber of my body kind
of locked in in a way dude I was reading
his moves I mean Grant he was probably
shitfaced but I'm just like I'm Neo in
The Matrix so fast dude drugs are so
great in that way that they make you get
out of your own way and you literally
like harness all of your potential
that's the double EDG that's the double
edge play that at a middle school yeah
disclaimer no which is why just saying
not even
close I have a Kaa rooll in my [__]
sometimes you you'll meet fans and I'll
be like that person smells and they're
hot too right you ever meet a hot person
that smells it's so jarring to meet like
a beautiful woman and they smell and
you're like
what you still have it cuz I'd love to
play with it my forkin
yeah we I wore them as earrings to the
Pink concert yesterday oh wow did she
see them when she was on stage when she
was flying by she grabed it I'd love to
wear them as earplugs on the road cuz I
always wear
earplugs go you hear about Gretzky's
daughter more I know I big fat titties
her wedding she had some crazy wedding
or some [__] yeah she married a
professional golfer Dustin Johnson who
plays live golf that Saudi Arabian blood
Money League no so it's Cristiano
Ronaldo playing that Saudi Arabian Blood
Money Beyonce just did the blood money
too and WWE just I think sold him to
Saab Saudi Arabia sing this P to Saudi
Arabia yeah when's Saudi Arabia going to
get into the podcast game I need some of
that [__] the offer is Right Saudi
Arabia if you're listening and we know
that you are shout out Saudi Arabia we
love we love what you goodes Good Vibes
here I love kingdoms you're buying up a
whole bunch of [__] over here have a IP
that you could buy I mean now that
Beyonce did it we got to pass we're all
fully clothed love it come on dude we'll
kill yeah the women will keep their
heads so this guy so my cover fale we
have on here will not have their hair
out from now on Saudi Arabia home to you
depends on the deal for with the
contract we'll go from there yeah we'll
cover their up go ahead imagine like
Saudi Arabian like podcast reads oh my
God yeah like you know it's you know
it's good oil yes
I love oil they just be all [__]
oil.com hey bab yeah I need a new
rollsroyce to drive around with h fresh
is normally America's number one meal
kit we'd have to say death to America's
number one meal
kit but yeah my vice principal molesting
me um oh yeah yeah so when I was a kid I
was a little troubled had some issues um
so he like took me under his wing and
his thing was like he would take like
troubled kids like under their wing and
like
help me get back on the basketball team
like help me get back on the football
team because I would get academically
suspended all the
time and in the beginning I was like
this guy's the coolest guy ever and for
people out there if you're young and an
old man turns out to be the coolest guy
ever odds are he wants to have sex with
you I'm just putting it out there I
don't know the statistics on it but odds
are when an older man is cool to a
younger boy that isn't related to him OD
already wants your unless unless that
man is Saudi Arabian then he's a good
guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
contact us at what hey bod gmail.com
yeah saes hat with
the I didn't even notice it wait wait I
but you just said that right but I'm
like an older guy that's nice to kids
all real old as [__] yeah like you're
old as [__] yeah and you don't work in a
school okay yeah yeah but if I was I'd
be really nice to the kids yeah would
you guys be nice to I mean I think I
just want to make sure we're not
painting ourselves as molest as if we're
nice to children oh no I'm nice to
children all the time you nice to my
kids the other day yeah you never know
though but I'm still I'm still she has
been quiet yeah nice to the other day
like I know I know she's my daughter's
hiding in the
basement s's coming she's like she's
like starts getting that F sh start
doing that
[__] but um yeah so I was like oh man
this guy's really cool um obviously was
was was grooming your boy so I was just
like okay like this guy is really cool
what was some cool things about him um
he would get me he he would take me out
of class like uh if I was having a hard
time if I was 30 minutes late for a
class he would write me a pass um he
would make sure that like if I was
failing I would get like that one
assignment that you do at the end of the
semester to pass so he was doing like
all these great things and I was like
damn like this dude sees my trauma you
know what I mean so I was like you know
this guy knows me guy could read me so
um we're talking um for 2 years like
just regular right and then like towards
the middle of my sophomore year
um he pulls me into his office and he
goes I have a workout routine for you so
I was like all right cool I played
football at the time so I was like yeah
you know what I mean so that's kind of
cool and then he was like yeah like if
you ever want to come here and work out
at my office you can if you want okay
which listen still is like it's weird
but we're not anywhere it's still not
molest area yeah you know what I mean I
can still see it being on the up and up
I can still see my office yeah that's
sharing common space like I'll do
push-ups at 14 while you you know write
progress oh he was there like watching
you yeah Oh I thought you like there was
some free weights there he's like come
in use no no no no um
so so that was the first I have two
older brothers okay so I knew what was
gay very early on okay cuz I was called
Gay from the time I was three you know
cuz when you have two older brothers
You're gay that's just how it is yeah
the little one is gay yeah you're little
gay bastard so that's just like what it
was so I I had a clue and plus uh I was
one of those kids that like watched Oz
like I wasn't supposed to but like I
watched a supr you up on on it yeah I
was up on all that type of stuff but I
never he was really good at hiding The
Vibes so um he was doing that uh the the
workout thing was a little weird and
then like a week later I had a bad day
in school and he brings me into his
office and he starts
crying and I was just like you good bro
like are you all right are you good
short say shorty you good yeah I was yo
yeah I fat joed him I was like yo sh are
you good in that moment you called up
Fat Joe and what he
did this was like three days after the
tournament so I'm just like yo I'm like
what the hell's going on man just like
no like I see like you're struggling so
much and like you know as a kid I
struggle too and I was like all right
cool like damn like what' you do like
like like tell your Spanish teacher to
like suck your dick or something he was
like no he's like I had this track coach
and I was like all right and he was like
always like riding me like always trying
to like be a dick to me so I'm like all
right not gay okay keep going and then
and then he's just like and then um you
suspected something right now you felt
uneasy yeah my gay flag went up
and how old are you right now I'm 34 no
no no how old oh oh yeah yeah I was 14
in my in like my I don't want to say gay
but my molestation flag went up yeah the
big red mestation I could be in a
situation right here yeah yeah yeah so
all right listen you know me I love to
travel I love to sightsee I love going
on history tours the only app that I use
is vur I've been using this for about 10
years 12 years I love VOR they have over
300 100,000 bookable travel experiences
in over 190 countries they offer
everything from simple tours to Extreme
Adventures and all the niche interesting
stuff in between VOR is the place to go
book memorable travelable
experiences I love it I mean I went to
um uh Glasgow Scotland I went to
Edinburgh Scotland uh London England
last year and I used VI tour I went on
one of the best underground walking
tours of Edinboro Scotland they have
like this whole kind of like dungeon
tour and the I went through vour and it
was one of the best experiences we ever
had I loved it when you book a travel
experience with VOR there's always
flexibility and support with free
cancellation payment options and 247
service and I can adhere to that I had
to cancel um a trip last minute vior
helped me out they booked me on another
one they readjusted for me you had a
person who could you know speak very
clearly that just helped me adjust do
all the things I needed to do so right
now download the VOR app and use the
code vior 10 that's vator 10 for 10% off
your first booking in the app one app
over 300,000 travel experiences you'll
remember do more with
VOR uh he starts like crying he starts
like talking about this coach and like
you know like when people are telling a
sad story they're like so I had this
coach yeah yeah fighting back yeah yeah
you know
like just like whoa this is going to be
[__] heavy cuz if anyone ever does
that midstory it's going to be like
something bad's coming after this cuz
you know they do not want to tell this
story so he's just like yeah so like
this coach was always mean to me uh and
always and then like one day I was in
the shower and he like came into the
shower like naked with me oo so now in
my mind I'm like damn that's crazy and
then my mind immediately goes to why the
[__] is he telling me the story like I
like I got in trouble in math class like
it's not like my math teacher pinned me
up against the [__]
Blackboard you know like equations like
one time I was doing long division nude
and the guy walked in nude with me and
didn't it yeah I was like yo what the
[__] well you're only 14 you're like
people go in the shower naked I only
ever go into the shower with my bathing
suit on I was yeah no I'm like that too
I'm a shy guy but um I remember just
being like he's like yeah and he like
got real Vivid he was like he pushed me
up against the thing and I was just like
yo what like I'm supposed to go to
[__] gym after this like how am I
supposed to process it so he was like I
just don't want to like like see the
same things happen to you and I was
like okay I was like all right like Mr
blank I was like it's all good like uh
and then I'm consoling like this like
molested older man in his office this
guy's like 50 years old dude I'm 14 he's
telling me about how his gym teacher
like tried to tickle his vou you know
what I mean like this is kind of crazy
so I'm just like okay and I remember I
just go back to class and I was like I
feel bad for him but there was something
incredibly weird about that
incredibly gross like why is he telling
me this like I'm 14 I'm a troubled kid
I'm vulnerable like this is kind of
sketch I don't even know if the story
was true but the way that he was crying
it felt real you know what I mean like I
said he did the leg slap look away so I
was like yeah this is bad um so he
leaves our school he uh he was a vice
principal he leaves our school becomes a
principal of the school right and we
were all sad because you know like up
like that was the one weird thing that
was always in my mind but otherwise he
was the [__] you forgot about that I
forgot about it I let it go you know I'm
just a kid like living life so he goes
to another
school uh in a year uh no I want to say
two and a half years or so
later um I'm watching news2 oh wow wow
I'm watching news2 no [__] and my mom
um was watching it with me and they were
like oh uh principal of soand so was
arrested for lewd conduct with a boy uh
uh 15 years of age in his car with one
of his students and his [__] P
picture pops up on the screen wow and
when I tell you my poor mother let out
the most blood curdling scream because
she knew how like close he was to me you
know what I mean and and like my C he
was close to my cousin he just like
wanted to [__] all of us I guess he just
wanted the whole bloodline so he was
just like you know he just [__] T
night how many low priories can I [__]
tonight that's what it was so my mom
lets out this blood curdling scream and
as soon as I saw his face it was like uh
you know in sha Shank Redemption when he
throws the rock through the poster yeah
I knew it I knew there was I just like I
heard it and The Rock just [__]
bouncing around I said this [__]
went through the wall so I just go I
look at the screen I just go I knew it I
knew it and now my phone just starts
blowing up blowing up because everyone
like even like old teachers are calling
me they're like hey man like are you
okay but I know what they want to ask
for real
did you ever like suck [__] like you
know what I mean like that's what they
want to ask me they're like you good man
I know that's a lot should we tell them
bring them
in oh
sh up until he was on the news it was
all
allegedly now so okay so that like has
got real [__] emotions right yeah
dude um and they found like like uh he
used to call me at night and like I
could hear him
breathing yo he used to send me birthday
cards like every year like send me
letters and my dad being the Italian guy
that he is every time like a letter he
would call me be like this guy's [__]
gay yeah you know like that's like where
his head tampon like tampaon yeah like
tampaon my dad would just be like
something's not right about this guy I
think he's gay and I was just like d
he's just like a nice guy gay isn't the
issue
that's how you know that old Italian
people couldn't Des you know you were
gay like gay and pedophiles were the
same thing in their heads they like
they're all doing this but I know he's a
pedophile but it with boys cuz
sucks he had sex with a little boy I
knew he was [__] gay yeah
yeah I'm going to report this guy hey
this guy this guy's a gay he's gay with
my son yay I want to try him for being
gay yeah we're trying him he's arrested
for p whoa I don't even know what that
is yeah first degree gay this what you's
got to get your yeah cuz then if it's a
girl they like well you know your
grandmother got married when she was 12
[__] it yeah it's happen to the old
country you know this this man had sex
with your 13-year-old so I don't care
about that it's so gay get him out of
here is my son gay now like I my son gay
yeah so like so okay so so you literally
that happens and then so like what so
what's next then did like the police
reach out to you yeah yeah yeah no the
police reached out to a couple people uh
but I kind of just like you weren't cute
enough I wasn't no dude I was so cute
when I was a kid believe like I
understood it I was like all right at
least he has good t i picture you in
this outfit as a kid I think it's so
cute did it there a little like Puerto
Rican boxer like did he make a move on
your cousin you said he talked to your
cousin no he he just like befriended all
of us he got the gayest with me okay
like um in terms of like you know what
he talked about what did he even like
what did he even mean when he said I
just don't want to see that happen to
you there's no he was trying to bait it
he B he grooming me sure but no I know
what he me I he [__] pin me during my
push-ups form logically though in his
mind he's like this happened to me I
just don't want to see it happen to you
it's like well who's doing that to me
yeah you know what I mean you like it
doesn't make any sense the craziest
thing too is like like all the girls
like from school where they're all up
there with like free blank signs like
there's no way there's no way and I'm
just in the back room like yeah there is
like there could be a way oh so they he
was being immediately defended oh yeah
the yeah our like entire like governing
like School body was like oh yeah like
yeah like no way no and I'm just there
like props you know what I mean I'm just
there like props props and they were
like uh I remember one time they asked
me they were like are you going to like
come up and like hold a sign or whatever
I said I'm not getting involved in any
of this yeah yeah I was like I'm not
getting involved in any of this and then
my parents sat me down and they were
like yo you just have to be honest with
us like did he ever do anything and I
was like N I was too I was too uh I lost
my virginity at 13 you know what I mean
so like I was yeah
him life is execution right you can we
have the death also is
death life and death is execution right
so it's about the that's the and that's
the hard part we all have the tools but
to use the tools this is where the game
comes in so it's how do we find ways to
execute and that's that's that's what
you got to find what works for you what
works for you may not work for the next
guy oh it definitely doesn't everybody
everybody has to find their own thing
right yeah I would say people program
but start the three of us you know the
three of us totally probably approaching
completely different ways I need to I
need to even like remind myself to not
sweat the small stuff even all the time
Kevin J best special I get I like the
greeting card bit I get um I get like
things in my head that just like like
they I can't get them out you know what
I mean and I had to like be like why are
you this way like why can't you just
change permanently I'm always fighting
the way my brain wants to go yeah I that
go ahead I was just saying I've had a
lot of conversations with you over the
years because I've been one of your Sig
confidants you know literally yeah you
know I'm all jacked up yeah I know
you're all [__] up he's writing a book
about some of theal stuff that we all
great you guys K it's on the shelves
next year um but I I I think the biggest
part is like you take to heart like you
get mad that you're like the way that
you are sometimes and I think that's
where it all comes from instead of just
accepting like that's the way you are
accepting that's what I going to see but
if that's the way I am then I'm going to
be thinking negative thoughts all the
time yeah but I think if you get rid of
the first first part of it and just be
like okay this is the way I am don't be
mad about that's that the way you are
you're saying that admitting that I'm
like that and just being comfortable
with is the first step in moving forward
from it I might be don't resist but I I
do say that I'm like that I'm the one
who says it no but you get mad at
yourself you're resisting you're still
resisting you're saying you're anger you
say with anger resist yeah you say
with this is something we talk about all
the time me and him this is the perfect
perfect example of me and S how we are
best friends and brothers meant to be
through the stars but complete Polar
Opposites a menu comes to the table okay
and we'll look I'll look at it and I'll
shut it and I'll be like I know what I'm
getting all right and then he'll come
and he'll be like oh whatever and he
waits to hear what everybody's having
but I'll already know what he had wanted
he just has to listen to everything take
it all in he already knew what he wanted
an hour ago right and that's the way it
goes but then put it in that we've been
in business for 20 years together right
and whenever a big decision had to be
made I would make it like that and then
s completely the way you look at it is
either he thinks enough or overthinks it
or whatever it was and him and I nine
out of nine and a half times would come
to the same conclusion but he had his
own process where he would talk
deliberate think about write charts
graphs Excel spreadsheets of all this
stuff and that's just the way his brain
works and we would always end up almost
always right to the same spot yeah right
so it's just Who You Are it's just
that's I have to make sure I am prepared
I have to do due diligence so that I
know that I'm not making uneducated
improper decision but that's okay but
that but but so but if you resist that's
who you are that's what Joe right that's
where the problems come in that's who
you are so you use it use all that
energy use all that energy that you do
to graph out the perfect you know weight
loss plan for yourself use all that
energy to work out the perfect family
balance situation for do all that
because we you know I don't I don't want
to do like anything you have been very
impressive to me as well you you you you
you talk to talk a lot you do you do you
you are you are very self-aware and you
put into practice a lot of things that
you preach try uh that's noted just know
over here noted do we note that it's
noted let me take a look at the it's
been noted
not what's the what's the funniest Saint
name um what's the what's the odest
saint name what's your confirmation name
Anthony
Christopher Paul Anthony D stepan what
about you it's Michael Michael what's
the funniest Saint name Google Google
funny saint
names um St Sal St bthad
St St sish s s St supicious St emeran
Tiana I went to St Mathias school a lot
of people don't know St Maas who's Mias
who Mias was the Mias was the 13th
Apostle Mias was
Mias was a backup Apostle he's like
kidana yeah he he he was a filling
Apostle I swear to God after Judas got
clipped he was the he was an apostle
yeah he was like a woo Apostle he was
like capana the woo Apostles yeah he was
the backup wow birth St birth wad is
really funny St birth W's good berwal um
is it almond almond is the L silent like
salmon almond right almond you say if
you say almond that's wrong it's not
almond it's not salmon it's not salmon
should be who who made that up yeah it's
stupid and how come you could say salmon
but then it's salmonella but it's both s
l m o n no why isn't almond spelled am m
o n d almond oh [__] almond oh she is
saying almond almond wow look at those
lips it's
almond
almond oh hit the slow button let us say
it slow almond almond D's like more s
sarcastic she's like almond
cuz when they say the jury to not be
biased by like what they hear outside
it's like no but you will you're a human
being what are you talking about yeah
it's like oh don't watch the Netflix
documentary about this case it's like
I'm gonna I'm watching it on my phone
right now I'm going to go with the
opinion of the director I don't care as
a human your humanness of you your
individual narcissism that we all have
takes over you're like I don't care what
happens to this person I want to get out
of here so I'm going to vote guilty even
though I don't think he's guilty to get
the out of here or vote not guilty just
so can leave so there has to be
something to prevent that I think once
you're in there you're getting wrapped
up in it don't you think you think so I
was say what percentage $40 a day for
jury duty that's insane I you think they
have sex back in the hotel room like you
think there's love affairs that go on
with the jury you get to know each other
in a fantasy world yeah they definitely
do right but I don't think you're
allowed to I think it's illegal to have
sex with a fellow jury member I don't
think you can have like a hotel rump see
let's see him stop me let's see him stop
me what is this new energy that you're
trying to achieve I'm tried to have a
glow up I tried to force a glow up dude
you've glown up you've you did it you're
all Glon up and you're all glones up and
you're all glown up thank you it's glown
up or glowed up glown up glown he wants
to get a glow up right GL
Stefani GL that's my new name I went to
go get testosterone from a doctor he did
my blood work beforehand he's like the
doctor gave it to you yeah it's legal
yeah it's street legal baby should be
mandatory dude it should be mandatory
you look at like what's going on with
people and how you know down and sad and
depressed and tired and F fat no sex
drive why can't we all feel like I'm
right here why
can't did you know that Jesus
historically it's a fact he had a huge
penis what yeah how could it be a fact
though because he was hung like
this hey yeah how did Helen Keller's
parents punish her as a kid how they
stuck the plunger in the toilet this has
been
[Music]
aab